(audience cheers)
- Welcome back,
it's my surprise birthday party!
My presents have been great food,
great drinks, and amazing friends.
And that's all about anyone needs in life,
that's what I'm saying.
♪ Happy birthday to you ♪
(audience cheers)
- Oh my god. (laughs)
You're so nice.
♪ Happy birthday to you ♪
(audience cheers)
- You're so nice!
Keep going, keep going!
♪ Happy birthday dear Kelly ♪
- Thank you. Thank you.
♪ Happy birthday to you ♪
- I love it.
(guest applaud)
(audience cheers)
Awesome, guys.
All right, Michael Ealy just
brought me a cake! (applauds)
I love it.
(audience cheers)
- Happy Birthday.
This a wonderful cake
from Big Sugar Bakeshop-
- [Kelly] Oh I love it.
- And they are apparently your favorite.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- So, here you go.
This is your cake.
- [Kelly] Those are the
cakes we get every year.
- It's an absolute honor
to be able to bring this
to you today
to surprise you here
on your birthday show,
you are the sweetest and the realest-
(audience applauds)
- Oh, thank you.
- [Michael] Person and the best
host on daytime television.
- Thank you!
- [Michael] Thank you so much.
- You're so nice!
- Thank you. Thank you.
Happy birthday! Come on!
- Oh, thank you!
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
I love it, we get cake.
Oh wait, that's not me, oh.
- But that's not all I brought.